[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We are
at KubeCon EU, 2018,
the first KubeCon of the year.
SPEAKER 2: When I first heard
about the Kubernetes project,
I was like, oh, my god.
This is amazing.
This is exactly what I needed.
This is a 4,000 people event.
It's amazing to see
the growth since then.
SPEAKER 3: When I joined
the Kubernetes project,
there were four
other contributors.
I'm now at the fifth KubeCon
that I personally attended.
There's over 4,300
attendees here.
And we've gone from
the initial few
of us building the
project to over 11,000
individual contributors.
SPEAKER 4: We are
definitely going
to see more and more attendees.
And as we see the
growing of KubeCon,
we see from focusing
more on contributors
to focusing more and more on the
ecosystem and also the users.
[MUSIC PLAYING]